Поки в Україні триває повномасштабне вторгнення Росії,
німецькі компанії не зупиняють свою роботу. Ба більше,
декі з них розширюють своє виробництво в Україні.
Так, наприклад, компанія "Крайзель" будує вже другий завод
із виготовлення будівельних сумішей. Цього разу - у Львівській області.
Тут на паспорті об'єкту видно, що ділянка 5 гектарів землі,
потужність підприємства тут написано 100 тисяч тонн на рік.
Але в процесі проєктування ще була збільшена.
Дві лінії буде 400 тисяч тонн на рік.
Тобто це означає, що це буде найбільше підприємство
з виробництва сухих будівельних сумішей в Україні.
Буде стояти надсучасне обладнання, де ми будемо перевіряти саме якісні,
кількісні характеристики нашої продукції.
Ніяка продукція не може вийти з нашої території, якщо вона
не відповідає локальним нормам і німецьким нормам.
Новий високотехнологічний завод має запрацювати вже наступного року.
Він входитиме у трійку найбільших виробництв цієї групи компаній.
У нас в групі "Фіксіт" 5 брендів, з якими ми працюємо.
Ми в Україні розвиваємо бренд "Крайзель". "Фіксіт" має в Європі 52 заводи.
Враховуючи те, що цей завод буде входити в трійку найбільших,
найпотужніших заводів Fixit group, це говорить про те, що наші німецькі колеги
бачать перспективу в Україні, бачать перспективу в розвитку і будують надсучасний,
високоефективний завод, який буде виробляти високоякісну продукцію.
І це дуже важливо. Це піднімає технічну, технологічну,
будівельну культуру в Україні. І, відповідно, я певен, що це стане з часом
певними стандартами на ринку України,
і весь ринок почне підтягуватися до цих стандартів.
Сам завод почали будувати влітку 2021 року. У лютому 22-го усі процеси
зупинило повномасштабне вторгнення. Та після місяця паузи будівництво відновили.
Після місяця призупинення проєкту було ухвалене рішення на рівні групи,
що ми маємо рухатися далі й будувати. Тому що війна піде,
а Україну треба буде відбудовувати. І саме відбудовувати високоякісними матеріалами,
високотехнологічними матеріалами. І "Крайзель" має досвід в цьому в Європі,
і міг би допомогти Україні.
Я казав часто, що для нас це було гейм-чейнджер.
Тому що ясно, що також у нас в центральній компанії ми мали дискусії,
як можемо зараз інвестувати. Там удари в Україні всюди -
і у Львові, і на Львівщині, і на Київщині.
Але також було питання, як це можливо зараз далі мільйони євро
посилати в Україну і будувати.
Що буде, якщо прилетять ракети і нароблять великої шкоди?
Тому важливим моментом стало запровадження німецьким урядом
механізму страхування воєнних ризиків для німецьких інвесторів
і торговельних компаній - у рамках Програми інвестиційних гарантій.
Компанія "Крайзель" першою в Україні отримала державне страхування
від уряду Німеччини. Ця страховка покриватиме усі ризики, пов'язані з війною,
а також трансферні ризики, ризики порушення договору тощо.
Участь у цій програмі передбачає одноразовий платіж і щорічний внесок
залежно від суми покриття інвестиційного ризику.
У грудні торік ми отримали гарантію від німецької держави -
це страхування для нас. Це був ключовий момент.
Ключовий момент не тільки для нас, але також для інших інвесторів із Німеччини.
Тому що німці дуже серйозно працюють, а також мають
професійний ризиковий менеджмент. І звичайно, тут іде війна,
маємо атаки проти України, це важко.
За моєю інформацією, профільне німецьке міністерство має нині
дедалі більше запитів, більше німецьких компаній хочуть отримати таку страховку,
як ми, щоб далі інвестувати. А це дуже позитивний сигнал,
це політичний сигнал, це сигнал для інвесторів щодо майбутнього.
Така урядова страхова програма існувала й раніше, проте тепер
до переліку додався пункт про воєнні ризики. Таке рішення німецького уряду,
на думку інвесторів, свідчить про впевненість Німеччини у майбутньому України.
Це сигнал німецькому бізнесу, щоб той не боявся інвестувати в Україну.
І це було зрозуміло, що це потенційний майбутній член ЄС.
Тому вкладати в Україну нині - це вкладати в майбутнє саме Європейського Союзу.
Тому для нас це було логічно. Так, це не було супербезпечно, але це було по-партнерськи.
12 мільйонів євро під час війни - це наш внесок у подальший розвиток.
Це перспективи для подальшого розвитку.  Ми говоримо не тільки про другий завод
- є перспективи ще і щодо третього заводу.
Звичайно, що для компанії це цікаво. Вона бачить перспективи розвитку саме в Україні.
І якщо компанія в такі непрості часи вкладає гроші в Україну,
це означає, що це країна, в яку компанія приходить всерйоз і надовго,
і хоче розвиватися саме в цій країні.
За даними Німецько-української торговельно-промислової палати,
загальна сума інвестицій німецьких компаній зменшилася
у порівнянні з довоєнним періодом.
Нині найбільше інвестицій в Україну надходить від концернів Bayer і Fixit.
Обидва роблять це в рамках програми інвестиційних гарантій від німецького уряду.
Порівняно з довоєнним періодом, так, звичайно, ризик є,
і компанії усвідомлюють цей ризик. Тому припускаю, що інвестицій
було би більше, якби не було війни. І я очікую, що кількість інвестицій зросте,
коли війну буде виграно, це точно. Багато компаній, які зараз інвестують,
звісно, мають спеціальні плани щодо цих інвестицій.
Вони отримують страховку інвестицій, що, звичайно, є розумною річчю.
Але, звісно, за цими інвестиціями стоять розрахунки
щодо українського ринку і віра в Україну, що цей ринок буде розвиватися далі
і що ці інвестиції будуть прибутковими.
Відколи почала діяти Програма інвестиційних гарантій німецького уряду,
кількість заявок на участь у ній збільшилася.
Це дозволить залучити ще більше інвестицій в Україну під час війни.
Нещодавно я почув цифру про те, що існує близько 50 заявок
на гарантії інвестицій в агентство, яке займається цими заявками.
50 - це досить значна цифра. Але як на мене, обсяги цих інвестиції
не дуже великі. Ймовірно, десь від 10 до 100 мільйонів євро.
Україні потрібно багато інвесторів. Адже потрібно відбудувати Україну.
Це дуже гарна країна, дуже добрі люди. Кожен знає, що має робити тут.
Тож, думаю, це добрий політичний сигнал і дуже допоможе українській державі.
У мінекономіки України вважають, що ця німецька програма
є вкрай важливим інструментом для підтримки та активізації бізнесу.
Але не лише Україна отримає від цього вигоду.
Німецькі компанії не інвестували б у ринок, який не обіцяє прибутків.
Якщо дивитися з точки зору Німеччини та німецьких компаній,
то Україна є величезним ринком. У Європі небагато країн
із 40-мільйонним населенням, тому потенційно це великий ринок.
Звісно, це теж певного роду ставка на післявоєнний період.
Ми розраховуємо на те, що Україна буде успішною і що після війни
буде добрий розвиток. Як прогнозує український уряд,
темпи зростання будуть від 5 до 7% на рік.
Крім того, є ринковий потенціал, а також є потенціал
кваліфікованої робочої сили в Україні.
Тому після війни буде набагато більше інвестицій,
зважаючи на українську винахідливість і великий потенціал.
Розширення німецьких інвестицій в Україну допомагає
великій програмі відбудови України вже нині.
Це створює робочі місця, вливає фінанси в економіку країни
і підвищує показники виробництва.
І свідчить про те, що німці вірять у великий економічний
потенціал України після війни.